[Music]
on this thursday night multiplying
omicron infections lead to new travel
measures
what it means for people flying to the
u.s and canadians driving across the
border we're going to fight this
variance with science and speed and if
you've already booked a trip what about
insurance and refunds the aftermath of
three atmospheric rivers in bc the
destruction now and reconstruction ahead
a lot of crews going around stripping
out people's houses and calls for royal
recognition
the push to honor the pandemic's
frontline workers with a royal medal
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there are more changes coming to entry
requirements for those traveling to the
united states international travelers
regardless of nationality or vaccination
status will need to get a negative test
one day before departure rather than
three days before
canada has just exempted u.s visitors
from stringent new rules which require
all other foreign air travelers to get
tested upon arrival in canada and
self-isolate while awaiting those
results heading into a busy travel
season it's leading to a lot of
confusion clarity on the rules plus
finding and paying for covid tests are
among the obstacles travelers face at
the same time the omicron variant is
spreading fast in south africa it's now
the dominant strain there we'll get to
that in just a moment but we begin with
mike armstrong in washington and
president biden's strategy to deal with
the new
variant president biden is hoping to
strike a balance the new pandemic
strategy is meant to fight a potential
winter surge and slow down the new
omicron variant but in a way that
doesn't hurt the economy it doesn't
include shutdowns or lockdowns but
widespread vaccinations and boosters and
testing a lot more
now in terms of new travel restrictions
the new rules don't go as far as some
predicted earlier in the week there is
no quarantine for travelers arriving in
the u.s something that was criticized
widely by conservative commentators it
may have been a trial balloon it may
have just been fabricated instead the
u.s will require a negative test for
anyone two years old and up arriving in
the country by air the u.s says in the
past required a negative test within 72
hours due to the omacron variant that
timeline is being cut down considerably
all inbound international travelers must
test within one day of departure
regardless of their vaccination status
or nationality
the biden administration also wants to
make getting vaccinated easier more
accessible hundreds of new family
vaccination clinics will be set up at
home testing is another front in the
fight the us is going to make it
mandatory for health insurers to cover
at-home test kits and for the uninsured
they're going to make free kits
available 50 million of them the bottom
line this winter you'll be able to test
for free
in the comfort of your home and have
some peace of mind
the us will also start a publicity
campaign to push more people to get
boosters and first and second shots but
it's that initial dose for people who
are resisting that would make the
biggest difference instead the countries
had to fight a public health emergency
with the weapon that's being politicized
we have people that are very eager to
get boosters and are demanding boosters
on one hand and we have people who don't
want even first doses on the other hand
so it's something that's made it much
more difficult there are about 60
million americans who haven't gotten a
first dose biden said today there's
polling that shows about 30 percent of
people who refuse to get vaccinated now
say the omacron variant has changed
their point of view biden says that's
good news that said
it does still leave a lot of people
donna all right mike armstrong in
washington tonight thanks
the omicron variant is also spreading in
canada the greater toronto area
confirmed its first case today a close
contact of a traveler who recently
returned from a country in southern
africa three other provinces quebec
alberta and bc have also reported cases
of the omacrom variant the delta variant
is still dominant here so what all the
experts are watching is whether omacron
will overtake it and what that might
mean
eric sorenson reports
third dose booster shots are beginning
to ramp up across the country in ontario
those aged 50 and over can get their
boosters starting december 13th that
will bring the number eligible for third
doses to more than 5 million we want to
be able to provide the third doses in a
timely fashion before the immunity fades
especially as we're seeing an increase
in cases related to delta and the
potential threat of omicron
to our communities as well federal
guidance is expected to be updated soon
several provinces are adhering to the
national advisory committee's october
recommendations to offer boosters to
anyone 70 or older along with vulnerable
groups saskatchewan and new brunswick
offered a 65 plus
others are now jumping well ahead
ontario at 50 and over by mid-december
and alberta will join manitoba with
boosters for anyone over 18 beginning on
monday given the fact that increased
transmission risk in the winter months
is lining up with some waning vaccine
effectiveness against infection over
time
the current evidence supports expanding
booster doses to add an additional layer
of protection quebec is not ready to
offer third doses to people under 70.
the premier says he's sticking with
current public health guidelines if they
change their mind i'll
change the way we proceed but right now
we say it's necessary only for people
over 70 years old what public health
officials don't know yet is whether
current vaccines can hold off the
omicron variant where omicron fits into
this is yet to be determined infectious
disease specialists expect some
protection but the real reason for
boosters now is to protect against delta
which accounts for the vast majority of
covid cases in canada and will continue
to be dominant for weeks to come we know
that antibodies wane over time and by
boosting people's immune responses to
get those antibody levels back up is
another measure to keep people safe from
developing severe infections back in
ontario they're vaccinating children
along with offering flu vaccines and the
chief medical officer of health says
there's also time for canadians to get
covet boosters before winter and the
omicron variant arrive in full force
eric sorensen global news toronto in
south africa omicron has now become
dominant and it is driving a sharp rise
in infections there cases have nearly
doubled in 24 hours there is still not
enough robust data from patients to
reach any conclusions about how
transmissible it is how capable it is of
evading vaccines and how sick people get
what is clear though is that south
africa is in the midst of a fourth wave
crystal commansing has the latest
it appears that what the world watch
happened with delta is now happening
with omicron it's certainly happening in
south africa where the new variant
identified a week ago is now responsible
for the majority of infections
south african scientists are working to
test and sequence their way to concrete
answers about the variance
transmissibility in south africa
where wso has already a team working in
genomic sequencing
we are deploying a surge team in gautam
projects to support surveillance and
contact racing
over the past few days confirmed
infections in south africa have exploded
70 percent of the virus genomes it
sequenced last month have been the new
variant we are worried about the rapid
rise in these numbers and we want to
deal with it
as if we are
in the fourth way and officials are also
seeing more cases of people being
re-infected with the virus
vaccination campaigns are underway but
those will take time south africa is
home to 60 million people only a quarter
of whom are fully vaccinated and where
previous infections offered some
protection against delta
experts here say with omicron that
doesn't appear to be the case
the president of south africa is angry
about the global response and the rush
on international travel restrictions we
stand firmly against any form of
health apartheid
in the fight against this pandemic
travel bans he says are unfair and
unscientific
given that it was our own scientists who
first detected
the omicron violent it is also a slap
in the face of
african excellence and expertise those
experts are now trying to figure out how
long this strain may have been
circulating
and how deadly it might be
krystal gamansen global news london
germany reported 73 000 new covent cases
today and is imposing tight restrictions
on the unvaccinated those who have not
had the shot can visit essential
businesses like pharmacies and grocery
stores but are otherwise barred from
public life outgoing chancellor angela
merkel calls it an act of national
solidarity to help ease the burden on
hospitals which are filling up germany
is also requiring masks in schools and
limiting the number of people at large
events merkel says vaccinations could be
mandatory by february about 68 percent
of germans are vaccinated
turning now to southern bc the sun made
an appearance today and the worst of the
storms have passed but the threat of
mudslides remains a number of highways
are closed fuel restrictions are in
effect and emergency orders are still in
place in abbotsford and the sumas
prairie cleanup and repairs are underway
and tonight we're getting our first
clear sense of the devastation on farms
the province says 819 farms are under
evacuation 628 000 poultry have died as
well as 420 dairy cattle about 12 000
hogs
and 110 bee hives are submerged
mike relay has been talking to people
about what they face in the days and
weeks ahead
at first glance the inside of ian mino's
house looks like a new build
but the floor's insulation and dry wall
it needs
are all things destroyed by the floods
that mining has torn out over the past
few days a lot of crews going around
stripping out people's houses getting
the getting it out before it all starts
to
mold this house was his oasis where he
could sit and enjoy the piece of the
summer breeze in the shadow of vedder
mountain now he's looking at a painful
reconstruction that could run over a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
eighty percent of which should be
covered by the province's disaster fund
no insurance
you can't get flood insurance here
because we're in a flood zone it could
take weeks for the flood waters to drain
out of the nine square kilometers of
sumas prairie two feet of rain or 0.6
meters was just too much for the land to
absorb but at least now the worst of the
storms has passed
allowing workers to take down the tiger
dam that had blocked off highway one
getting back to normal is going to take
some time two elementary schools have
been closed indefinitely until they can
be cleaned up and cleared of any mold
issues until then students will have to
learn remotely or bust to a temporary
classroom elsewhere
there's just so much that's still
unknown we found at terry woodland and
his wife connie near the trailer they
bought in may i think there's a bug in
around this area here somewhere they
managed to save most of their belongings
everything else is a question mark are
you going to be able to live in the
trailer
i'm not sure yet gotta check into that
uh insurance
um question mark as well
the only certainty is their uncertainty
about returning to this small corner of
the fraser valley they saw as idyllic in
reality it's a flood plain the option to
move closer to connie's native arizona
they say is appealing for obvious
reasons and look it's starting to rain i
know go away
after the november people here had most
could just use a break
mike durley global news abbotsford bc
the omicron variant and your vacation
coming up what to do if you've booked a
getaway or are thinking about it
rideau hall's internal cyber network has
been hit by a breach the office of the
secretary to the governor general
confirms there is an unauthorized access
it says the impact is unclear and
improvements are being made to
strengthen the network the canadian
center for cyber security is involved in
the investigation rideau hall says
protecting the personal information of
all who work with and interact with the
office is a priority
canadians will get a snapshot of the
state of the country's finances on
december 14th that's the date the
government has set for a fall economic
update it's a hot topic as parties
debate legislation to retool pandemic
benefits and as canadians deal with
soaring inflation abigail beeman reports
of a continuation of the poor excuse of
it's just inflation
justin flation the conservatives new
repeated critical catch phrase as they
hammer on inflation in the house of
commons there's prices going up across
the board the finance minister now
promising a new look at the state of
things i'm pleased to announce that i
will be giving an economic and fiscal
update to canadians on december 14th
december 14th just days before the house
rises for the holidays they are dragging
their feet you know it took two months
to come back here to work in parliament
we still don't have any committee
organized and they are waiting last week
before the christmas break trudeau
government wants to deliver a
big
sack of inflationary coal
for every family just in time for
christmas
october saw the highest rate of
inflation in nearly two decades 4.7
percent and the conservatives are trying
to blame it on liberal policies though
economists say that's not quite fair and
it's a phenomenon currently experienced
across the globe there's no silver
bullet here to solve this type of
inflation driven by global pressures and
supply chains
the best thing that canadians can do is
be patient as for what's in the update
major proposed spending measures are
already on the table 7.4 billion dollars
in retooled pandemic benefits were
announced in october bill c-2 was
introduced in the house last week and so
far the opposition says they won't
support it the ndp says it doesn't do
enough to help people still struggling
and the conservatives have a number of
demands including getting the finance
committee back up and running to study
it lots to work out with just a couple
more weeks until the holiday break
abigail beeman global news ottawa
in edmonton members of the metis nation
are preparing to meet pope francis at
the vatican later this month metis first
nations and inuit delegations will each
have an hour to speak privately with the
pontiff about the role of the catholic
church in residential schools
so to have that acknowledgement
is is a great
is a great gift to us
and we have our stories going there
and some of these stories are
cemented
they're
they're already
done
but there should be new stories coming
back
and that's what i'm hoping for are the
new stories
leaders and residential school survivors
from the metis nation will meet with
pope francis on december 18th the pope
is planning to visit canada but no date
has been set
omicron anxiety some advice before you
pack your bags
it's been a busy few days for canadian
travel agents the newly discovered
omicron variant and subsequent travel
bans and changing restrictions are
creating a lot of confusion this holiday
season and gaviola has more on what you
need to know about air travel and
insurance
before news of the omicron variant broke
canada's airline industry was set to hit
a pandemic era high this holiday season
it'll take time to see whether this
results in a rash of cancellations we we
are hearing of course people are saying
like should i be concerned
am i at risk of getting stuck overseas
if i take a flight now travel insurance
quotes on rates.ca are up nearly 300
percent this fall compared with this
time last year interest in travel surged
and with a newly discovered variant
interest in insurance has spiked too
the good news is more than half of
travel insurance providers across canada
now provide options to protect yourself
in the event of a covert related medical
emergency or trip disruption in the case
of travel cancellation insurance what's
covered and what isn't depends on a
variety of factors and there is
insurance that will cover you regardless
of the circumstances but you'll pay
extra for that
more commonly there's insurance that
will reimburse what you've paid whether
that's a deposit for a flight or hotel
or prepaid the full amount in the event
of a cancellation with some exceptions
you have to read the fine print
and keep an eye on government advisories
and warnings which can change quickly
being in a part of the world that
federal authorities suddenly deem unsafe
can render your insurance null and void
when it comes to flying if the airline
cancels your flight for reasons within
its control you're owed a full refund
not a voucher but omicron is beyond the
carrier's control evolving bans and
restrictions can cancel your trip or
stop you from making a connecting flight
and you may be on the hook for that
this consumer advocate says if you
cancel because you're worried about what
could happen while you're abroad you
have to rely on insurance if your ticket
doesn't offer flexibility if you decide
to cancel out of your subjective
possible even very reasonable concerns
then it is a matter for your insurance
and the terms and conditions that were
set out in their analysis tariff and
possibly other terms and conditions
attached to the ticket anne gaviola
global news toronto
next the push to give canada's frontline
workers royal recognition
you're watching global national
when queen elizabeth marked 60 years on
the throne in 2012 the canadian
government seized the moment to honor
its own citizens the diamond jubilee
medal was created and has been awarded
to canadians from all walks of life for
their service to community and country
well as the queen approaches her 70th
year on the throne there are calls to
honor frontline workers who have given
so much in the pandemic but as david
aiken explains there are no plans for
more medals
during the 2012 jubilee special medals
were given to thousands of deserving
canadians rcmp members the military
volunteers indigenous leaders
prince charles himself toured the
country to hand some out as did then
prime minister stephen harper thank you
very much
olympic gold medalist adam vancouverdin
now an mp himself also received a
diamond jubilee medal for his
accomplishments in sport the athletes
were all brought up to uh the house of
commons to go on to the onto the carpet
and meet a whole bunch of mps and it was
a very special moment for a lot of us
but there may be no such special moments
for deserving canadians next year the
queen's platinum jubilee year
the royal canadian legion among others
has been pushing the trudeau government
for two years to commit to a medal
program but so far its requests have
been ignored are we going to lose
something by not having a diamond
jubilee medal
we'll live
but we'll live more poorly because of it
quebec mp pierre paulus even made a
direct appeal writing a letter to the
queen you know with the panamic we have
a lot of stories of people being
involved and with 12 canadians and i
don't understand why justin trudeau and
his government don't want that meadows
another mp cheryl gallant put a petition
before the house of commons with more
than 1800 signatures asking for a
jubilee medal program we're so
blessed to have the queen with us after
70 years of her service but with less
than a month until the new year the
government is undecided we're looking at
the different options at this moment to
see what's better to to celebrate the
event so we'll have more information
later the metal program in 2012 did cost
eight million dollars and attitudes
about canada's connection to the
monarchy particularly among quebecers
and indigenous peoples have changed i
know there's a lot of conversations
around the monarchy and the relevance in
2021
but if it's an opportunity to thank
frontline workers healthcare workers and
volunteers over the last two years that
we've had i think it's worth it the only
thing the federal government has
committed to so far a grant program
service clubs local legions and so on
can apply for up to five thousand
dollars to produce events to celebrate
elizabeth's 70th year on the throne
donna seven years david aiken in ottawa
thanks and that's global national for
this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is tofino bc we'd
love to see your canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching colleen christie
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow and
i'll see you on saturday for the new
reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you